Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, and this video is
the series of other set of your T&A, but this is
on the dietary consideration. So
what kind of diet is best for me? That's the question a lot of people have.
Should I be eating vegan? Should I be doing the gap-statch? Should I be doing the keto diet?
Should I be doing
a paleo diet? Should I
just eat all the sugar that I want? I
don't know. So your genetics can tell us some
some hints, but nothing is perfect to find the diet for you.
Nothing is going to be perfect. The genetics will give us hints, but
we'll talk about that. In all my other videos, I say that, you know, you don't
make complete dietary decisions based upon your
genes because there's other things that go along with it.
They're environmental factors that affect
what you should be eating. Your
current diet and your past diet for over the years
had current environmental factors. Like, do I have
Lyme disease? Do I have a chronic age pylori infection? Do I have
heavy metal toxicity? Am I living under enormous amount of stress? That
balance is our microbiota. If we have a lot of
intertoxid production because of a chronic infection,
that decreases our immune system or could throw us into an autoimmune
situation. Any gut inflammation is going to equal inflammation
everywhere else in the body. So inflammation of the gut equals
inflammation of the brain and the rest of the body. That affects our blood
barrier. That affects our immune system's response to every disease
and can set us up for every disease. So you could argue that
the gut really is the first tell-tell side of disease everywhere.
So start by healing. The gut is really important.
Lots of times our cancer patients struggle with that is a
why are we deal with the gut? I have brain cancer.
If we deal with the gut, I don't have breast cancer,
not colon cancer. But if you don't heal the gut, you don't balance
the microbiota or work on that because it's not like you're going to
heal it. It's that you're going to be constantly working on that.
You are going to be constantly chasing your tail.
I've also said that just looking at the genetics is not
the proper way to look at what you should be eating or
should it be eating because there's more to that.
The best way to test for food sensitivities that necessarily overall
diet, but should I be eating gluten? Should I be in tapioca?
Should I be in corn? Should I be this? Is to do a blood test.
The lab that I recommend that's said over and over is through
Syrex labs. That's the best lab to do that blood test because
it looks at different peptides. Let me explain what that is.
When you're looking at gluten, for instance, the protein that people
are sensitive with gluten is the gliadin. When you look at
dairy, people are looking at, I don't take people off of dairy
because they have lactose intolerance. Lactose is the sugar in dairy.
You go off of dairy because you have intolerance or sensitivity
to or antibodies to the k-seed. That's the protein.
It's the protein in the foods that really causes the issue.
It gets even deeper than that. With gliadin, some people will say,
well, I had my doctor run a test for gluten, a blood test for
gluten, and it was negative, so I could eat gluten.
I hate to tell you the bad news, but the test is worthless.
If that blood test for gliadin antibodies or gluten
antibodies would only be positive if you had leaky gut bad enough
that the entire gliadin protein was getting across the gut.
That means you are really sick. Your gut borders are so open
that a giant multi-trailer semi could drive through there.
Because what a protein is here, let me show you.
A protein is a long chain of amino acids, so think of this
as a long chain of different amino acids here.
What a protein is is the sequence of that amino acids.
The sequence of a specific amino acid chain makes it gliadin gluten.
Another sequence of a different amino acid chain makes it a different
type of protein, k-seed in the case of dairy.
In your intestinal tract, your enzymes, think of it as these scissors here,
will go and cut up these amino acids, the bonds between the amino acids.
So it breaks up the protein, so how you break down a potent protein is with
enzymes that break the bond, the chemical bond, between the amino acids.
And eventually the desire is in the process of digestion.
It's to snip every one of these bonds, or at least get them down to a group of two
that's called a dipeptide.
If it's in a group of more than one, in a group of two or more,
it's called a peptide, which is a piece of a large protein.
So enzymes in your intestinal tract, made by your pancreas,
break down proteins into peptides, and eventually down into amino acids.
Now it's not gluten anymore.
So if I had a healthy gut wall and I had a really healthy pancreas,
that's two mass assumptions that we've already gone over most American situations,
I would break down all my proteins into amino acids and that the amino acids are small
enough to cross through the gut border and to get into the bloodstream.
They're not protein, they're not protein anymore.
It's just an amino acid.
It's not gliated or gluten anymore.
It's simply an amino acid.
And then our body uses that amino acids to make other proteins.
That's why you'd consume proteins because you want to break them down into amino acids,
so your body can make certain other proteins and enzymes to do other functions in the body.
That's the whole purpose.
The problem comes in is when we have ill digestion, so we have a decreased digestion,
so we're not breaking those down very well.
And we have a leaky gut, so that instead of the gut border,
not allowing any more than a single amino acid or a dipeptide to amino acids bond together,
across it will allow larger things across, like a peptide of five amino acids,
a peptide of 15, a peptide of 40, et cetera.
Now these are gliated peptides.
And when they get into your bloodstream, so here's a picture of leaky gut borders,
allowing things in instead of having tight junctions,
it allows things in that never should have got in, like food antigens,
because it's something that your immune system is going to go,
what the heck is that?
Let's kill it.
Because it's not an amino acid, it's not a dipeptide, it's a larger peptide.
And your immune system doesn't recognize it, and it says we need to kill it.
So if that takes place, now you spark an immune reaction to kill that thing.
Of course, it's not going to be able to kill it because there's nothing to kill,
but you can develop antibodies against that peptide.
That's not a good thing.
So what you need to do is not run an antibody test against the entire gigantic long chain amino acid
of amino acids in one protein called gliated,
you need to run a test for the individual peptides,
so that you can really see if your gluten sets tip.
So I know it's kind of hairy, but go with me on this.
The test that you want to run is a test through Syrex,
and they have multiple different panels, but this is Syrex lamps.
They are the best at running that test and getting very specific,
and getting, you know, not showing you a whole bunch of foods that you don't have to stay away from.
These are showing the exact peptides that you actually have antibodies to.
So that's how you would find out if you need to stay away from, from, um,
KC and gliated, which is gluten, but in truth, if anybody has chronic issues,
you really should stay away from gluten for sure,
and you should think about giving up gliated as well.
Now, also in my other videos, I have specific videos on histamines,
so I'm not going to get into that in this video here, so,
but watch the videos on histamines, because that goes into a 15-minute,
20-minute lecture just on that.
But there's some other things that people are sensitive to that you can see on the genetics,
and that's sulfur, sulfite, sulfates, and oxalates.
So I just want to touch a little bit about that, and I want to talk a little bit about glutamate.
Now, all of those things are coming down to this pathway,
and they give you what to give credit to seekinghealth.org for this beautiful picture here.
But this pathway is part of my Transulferation pathway.
The purpose of the Transulferation pathway is to make SOD through that pathway,
make glutathione through that pathway.
So those are things that get rid of reactive oxygen species,
and reactive nitrogen species are their intercellular antioxidants.
But also in that pathway is how you break down sulfur and sulfates,
how you get rid of that, and then ultimately through your urea cycle.
It's also how you get rid of oxalates and how you deal with oxalates.
And so those could all be issues, people will say they have a sulfur allergy,
or they react negatively to drinking wine,
and they think they have a sulfite allergy.
Well, I'll tell you about 99% of quote-unquote sulfite allergies,
are not sulfite allergies, they're defects in the Transulferation pathway.
So supporting those defects can really help you be able to digest those things
and be able to break them down.
Because if you can't break them down, then they become a sensitivity in your body.
So we'll talk a little more about oxalates in a bit.
Glutamate is also produced through that pathway.
Glutamate is an essential nutrient in your body.
It acts as a neurotransmitter in your brain.
It added your muscles as well.
Glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter.
It's excitatory to your brain.
It does really wonderful things.
It helps you get up in the morning, helps you concentrate, helps you stay focused.
The problem is, is if you have these defects here,
the BHMTOA to the CBS699 defect,
you can have, you produce seed more glutamate and ammonia than really you should.
Now, that tends not to be a problem if you're able to get rid of it.
In the case of ammonia, if you have very few defects in the urea cycle,
then that's okay.
You typically will be able to flush out that ammonia through your kidneys.
That's typically where you're going to lose the ammonia.
Glutamate, on the other hand, if you produce too much glutamate
and you can't get rid of it,
the gene that gets rid of glutamate is the GAN1 genes.
So, if I have defects that look like this with my BHMTOA in the CBS699,
excuse me, on the upper left-hand corner, plus I have the inability
to convert glutamate to GABA, which is a call me neurotransmitter,
then I'm going to probably have excess glutamate in the brain.
It gets worse, because there's other genes that we don't actually show up your profile,
but I get to look at them. Fortunately, we don't have them on the patient profile,
at least at the time of this taping.
If I by the time you're listening to this,
there's a GLS gene that they're finding that glutamate converts to glutamate
through this GLS gene.
And if a person has defects like this, the 2, 2, 1, and 1,
that this person has, defects on this gene speed the conversion of glutamate to glutamate.
Well, what does that mean? Well, glutamate isn't a amino acid.
That is phoned in proteins. Excuse me.
Okay, so where am I getting that?
Well, every time you meet meat, or every time you meet beans,
or every time you eat anything that has protein,
you're going to consume some glutamate.
And you need glutamate, so glutamate is good.
That, in fact, most gut healing products that are out there in the market
contain a lot of glutamate, because L glutamate, that's typically what you'll see on the label,
is extremely healing to the intestinal tract of the epithelial cells.
So glutamate is actually a good thing.
The problem is, is if I have these GLS gene defects,
I'll convert glutamate to glutamate quite quickly.
And if I have the GAD1 defects, that is covered by this,
I don't convert glutamate to GABA.
So I'm going to end up with excess glutamate.
Well, what's that going to cause?
Well, excess glutamate is going to increase OCD type symptoms,
increase anxiety, increase the inability to let things go.
Person perseverates on thoughts.
Can't let thoughts go.
They can perseverate at ideas.
They can perseverate in actions.
They can't settle down.
They tend to be worriers.
They tend to, would describe themselves as depressed,
but it's not real true depression.
It's anxiety.
And those are all glutamate things.
They tend to have OCD things.
It can be, it can lead to ticks.
It can lead to Tourettes.
So glutamate is a bad thing in excess.
Remember, nothing is a good thing.
Nothing is a bad thing per se.
But glutamate is certainly a bad thing in excess.
And typically, we don't see very many people with low glutamate levels.
We see a lot of people with high glutamate levels.
As a matter of fact, you've heard me say in other videos
that the food industry purposely puts glutamate in foods
because it's stimulatory to your glutamate receptors
and it makes you addicted.
It's called a flavor enhancer.
You've heard of the most common, which is bud of sodium glutamate.
The flavor enhancer makes you taste good
because it's stimulatory to your tongue receptors
and then your brain glutamate receptors.
The problem with this is that over time,
you actually make more receptors on the cell membranes.
So you have cells with excess glutamate receptors
and you become even more sensitive to it.
Your microglia also are stimulated with excess glutamate,
which stimulates an immune response in your brain.
And that's not a good thing.
So it causes inflammation in the brain.
So it's excitatory in the brain.
It causes inflammation in the brain.
And that inflammation actually causes neurological degeneration.
So new studies are out that excess glutamate
can lead to early dementia, memory loss issues, brain fog,
early Parkinson's, and early Alzheimer's.
It's not a good thing to have.
So people will say, oh, I react to MSG.
If you react to MSG, you have excess glutamate already in your brain.
Okay?
So if you are attracted to nacho cheese Dorito chips
or flavored chips, or processed foods that have any thing
that has natural flavor in it,
here's a list of some MSG-containing things.
They don't have to list it as glutamate anymore.
It can be listed as a whole bunch of different things.
Barley, malt, malt, flavor, soy sauce, extract, soy proteins,
protein lease insides, all these have glutamates in them.
And so it's in a lot of different processed foods.
And if you're eating a lot of processed foods, pretty much guaranteed
you have excess glutamate.
And this is very damaging to your brain.
These are called neurotoxins.
These are listed as neurotoxins because they're toxic to your brain.
This is a major cause of ADD-ADHD issues.
Okay?
Super important.
But from a genetics standpoint, you can really see the picture
and you can say, well, you are going to be more susceptible
to this because you have these defects and you make too much
and you don't get rid of it very much.
You don't get rid of it very well.
The hyperabodia leads to all sorts of problems, too.
So dealing with this is important.
So what do you do?
How do you do that?
Well, you have to stay away from glutamates.
You have to read labels.
Eat fresh things.
You know, go back to that slide and look at that.
Google different high glutamate foods that you want to stay away from.
Basically anything processed.
Start by an organic and start eating better.
I mean, that's the key.
You have to not go out to eat.
Sorry, I was at the day of the day.
Applebee's that went over there.
I was about two years ago when I said, what did they say?
I'm highly allergic to MSG.
I'm not.
But I said, I'm highly allergic to MSG.
Could you give me a list of things on your menu
that don't have MSG?
The waitress went to the back room, came back about 10 minutes later.
It said, every single thing on our menu has MSG.
That's very scary.
So I understand that it's everywhere.
So try to cut down on that as much as possible.
It could really help you with a lot of your symptoms.
So if you have these defects that we just listed on this,
really watch glutamate levels that would help a lot.
Well, glutamate, we have to try to talk about protein because
remember glutamate in protein breaks down into glutamate.
But other things, what is protein?
Protein is a series of amino acids, right?
So some of those amino acids break down into other neurotransmitters as well.
Tyrosine, fetalality, and tryptophan, break down into serotonin,
dopamine, epinephrine, and nor epinephrine.
So, well, that's really good.
So you need those neurotransmitters, right?
But if I have the defect, like you see here,
on the left, it says serotonin in the mild defect.
If you have a double or single allele defect on this gene right here,
and you're having symptoms of excess serotonin,
which what are symptoms of excess serotonin?
Well, it could be fits of rage, fits of anger, easily agitated,
easily upset, prone to just be short tempered.
It just kind of have an angry personality.
And by the way, you might have to ask some loved one if this is you,
because many times you don't recognize this.
You say this is just who I am.
That is a sign of excess serotonin.
Excess dopamine symptoms would be similar to glutamate,
in that you could be fixated, ADD, ADHD,
can lead to OCD type symptoms.
You're a very driven person, which could be very good,
but maybe to the point of being a workaholic,
excessively driven, get stuck on something,
and can't let that go.
This could be your personality, and you choose careers based upon your genes.
So it's not a bad thing, but it's good to know how to cushion that a little bit.
So if you're not happy that you're easily bite people's head off,
which you shouldn't be happy about,
what you could do to calm down the serotonin production,
would be to calm down the consumption of foods that would stimulate more serotonin production.
Well, what are those?
Well, I just said that tryptophan, tyrosine,
and fetalality are precursors to serotonin,
dopamine, and the rest of the neurotransmitter.
So if I cut back on those, maybe I'm not going to go vegan,
but I'm going to cut back on those,
I will slow down the production of serotonin.
A person could see symptom changes literally in a day.
They decrease their protein consumption
and their serotonin levels drop down.
And you see this a lot with people that have aggressive personalities.
The aggressive personality has excess serotonin
if they're living off of protein
because they started a bodybuilding program.
So they're eating meat like crazy.
They get more aggressive,
and you see this many times with males and sometimes females
that are abusive personalities.
They become more abusive, more aggressive.
The more protein they eat,
the more they work out.
They're stimulating amino acid breakdown from protein
that amino acids turn into other things.
And it goes through the myopter pathway.
It turns into neurotransmitters
and it affects the person's behavior.
So there's a genetic reason why a person could be overly aggressive.
Why a person could be a personality that could be a little nasty.
So when I talk to patients with that,
many times they'll put them on a low protein diet,
cutting back on the precursors.
So it can be very helpful.
The flip side of this is true.
So if I have symptoms of low serotonin and low dopamine,
we can't even get out of bed today.
I just don't feel good.
I just can't get going.
They have no drive.
That means their dopamine is down.
And they're sad and they're blue and they're melancholy
and they're depressed.
These people should not be eating a vegetarian vegan diet.
They need protein.
And I've told lots of people,
you know what?
You need to get up and eat a piece of chicken.
What for breakfast?
Yes, get up and eat some protein.
Many times people that are at a vegetarian vegan diet
that is a code word for eating tons of carbs and sugar.
That's not good for you.
That's not good for that type of person.
Eating more carbs and sugar might actually be beneficial
for the person who's overly driven and overly aggressive
and short-tempered and cutting back on the protein,
eating more greens, eating more veggies.
Follow me on that.
Telling the right-hand corner is the MATG.
The MATG takes methionine and converts to SAM.
A person with a lot of defects.
If this was a cancer person, patient in my office,
and they had this many defects in the MATG,
we would cut back on their protein consumption.
I'm not in favor of every cancer patient.
But especially if you have MATG defects,
you don't want to be feeding excess methionine
because methionine and glutamine can feed cancer.
Cancer cells can feed off of glutamine and methionine.
Some amino acids can actually feed cancer cells.
If you have a lot of MATG defects,
cutting back on protein can be beneficial.
Follow me.
There are two completely different pathways
that could suggest eating more protein or less protein.
Because you have to look at the precursors.
Here's foods that have a lot of methionine in them.
You can pull up these methionine lists.
Basically it's protein.
If I have a lot of MATG defects,
then I'm going to cut back on my methionine.
Cut back on my protein.
And again, if you're not having any symptoms,
and you don't have any cancer,
then maybe you should just leave it alone.
But I'm just talking about people that methionine won't give you the symptoms.
But if you're dealing with cancer,
and you have a lot of MATG defects,
I would highly suggest you go at a lower protein type diet.
Oxylates are something different.
They're produced through the trans-alpheration pathway.
And they're also produced in your gut.
And you can't get rid of them in your gut
when you have leaky gut issues.
So I'm actually making a whole video on oxylates to help you understand that.
Because it is a problem.
And the symptoms that it will really cause
are going to be gout symptoms.
Gouty arthritis symptoms.
Can't even be rheumatoid arthritis symptoms.
Can't even be degenerative arthritis symptoms.
And the most common thing you think with oxylates are kidney stones.
So if you are prone to kidney stones,
ever had kidney stones,
or familiarly have had kidney stones,
like your parents have had kidney stones,
really important to number one, stay hydrated,
to support these different pathways,
and to avoid foods that have high oxylates in them.
And some of these are really good foods.
You just want to make sure you're not eating them in excess.
Okay, so let's look at this thing.
Oh, Swiss chard and beets.
Oh, those are supposed to be so good for your raspberries.
They're really good for you.
Yeah, they are, but just because Swiss chard
or kale and spinach is good for you,
it doesn't mean you should be making
a spinach kale shake every day.
And that's what you consume for your breakfast.
Too much of a good thing can be a bad thing for everybody.
It's about balance, remember.
Maybe eating these giant hamburger and fries
is never good for you, but it's about balance,
even with that.
You don't have to become a guru to stay healthy.
So it's about having that balance,
about doing the right thing 80% of the time, really.
That's really the secret to health.
So you support the snip, you look at your diet,
having that balance diet.
So that's the initial kind of brush over dietary things.
Make sure you watch some of the other videos
under this section, and also make sure you come back
to this section, because I'm constantly adding new stuff.
So refresh your page or go back to the page,
and look, because there'll be more things
that can help you along the way.
And as new information comes out, I'm constantly studying
going to seminars and such.
I try to put it on videos for people to learn from.
Again, you are doing the genetic pathway,
but if you decide to do what to become a patient,
you follow the first steps thing on our website.
And please be respectful of our 23 me agreements.
You can't call the office and just ask a quick question.
We can't do that ethically.
So I appreciate it.
I hope you were blessed by this, and you learned much from it.
Look at your report.
And even just because I suggested some things,
you may look at your report and go,
wow, this one really fits me.
I'd rather do something different.
It takes something different.
We have a ton of things.
On our web store available for you,
so please feel free to browse that too.
Thank you so much.
Bye-bye.